I’m sure you’ve all heard about random
college students and young adults turning
a couple hundred or thousand dollars into
hundreds of thousand or even millions by investing
into momentum cryptos.
There was even some guy who turned $8000 into
$5.7 billion by investing into Shiba Inu.
If you’ve made life changing amounts of
money with these altcoins congratulations,
that’s really quite awesome.
But, there’s someone who’s making a lot
more than all of these guys while taking on
far less risk, and that’s of course the
crypto brokerages.
You know what they say, when there’s a gold
rush, you don’t wanna be digging for gold,
you wanna be selling the shovels, and that’s
exactly what Sam Bankman did.
In May of 2019, Sam launched his crypto trading
platform FTX, and now he’s worth $26.5 billion.
And did I mention that he's only 29 years
old.
Forbes claims that Sam is actually the richest
person in crypto.
Satoshi Nakamoto is of course richer, but
if we just look at known figures, Forbes is
probably right.
So, here’s the story of Sam Bankman, and
how he became the richest known crypto figure.
Taking a look back, Sam was born on March
6, 1992 in Stanford, California.
Both of his parents were law professors at
Stanford, so I think it’s safe to assume
that Sam had a well off childhood.
He spent a lot of his free time reading Harry
Potter and watching the San Francisco giants.
As for school, he attended a small private
school in the bay before scoring a spot at
MIT where he majored in physics.
Physics is one of the hardest majors to complete
if not the hardest, and Sam was doing it at
MIT, so you would think that college consumed
all of his time.
But, Sam says that he was able to half ass
his way through it.
Apparently, he spent most of his time playing
video games including Starcraft and League
of Legends as opposed to studying.
So, we’re probably looking at a child prodigy.
Initially, Sam was looking to become a physics
professor similar to his parents, but as he
developed a strong interest in ethics and
morality, he slowly strayed away from this
path.
Sam was especially interested in effective
altruism and utilitarianism.
Instead of donating money to trendy causes,
Sam believes that one should donate money
to causes that will objectively do the most
good.
For example, causes that save the most amount
of lives or create the most amount of income
per dollar donated.
In order to make such an impact though, Sam
knew that he needed big money and he simply
wasn’t going to get there by being a professor.
So, instead of pursuing higher level degrees,
Sam took on a lucrative finance job at a quantitative
firm called Jane Street Capital.
Unlike other crypto billionaires, Sam never
really cared about crypto and he wasn't an
early adopter by any means.
In fact, crypto didn’t catch his attention
till 2017 when Bitcoin was running from a
few thousand dollars to $20 thousand.
Even then, he didn’t really care about the
fundamentals of Bitcoin or what it stood for.
He wasn’t interested in Bitcoin’s promise
of being an inflation hedge or it’s decentralized
nature.
What he was interested in though was Bitcoin’s
inefficient markets.
One day, Sam noticed that you could buy bitcoin
in the US and sell it on secondary markets
for a substantially larger amount.
And that’s how it all started.
Sam says quote, “I got involved in crypto
without any idea what crypto was.
It just seemed like there was a lot of good
trading to do.”
Something else that attracted Sam to crypto
was the lack of regulation.
Opening up a traditional trading firm requires
a lot of licenses and help from lawyers which
is not cheap.
But, with crypto, basically anyone could open
a trading firm especially if it wasn’t based
in the US.
Sam wasn’t the only one trying to leverage
this opportunity though.
Exploiting this price difference to make profits
is actually an established form of trading
called arbitrage trading.
Anyway, Sam would end up quitting his job
and he would start an arbitrage crypto trading
firm called Alameda research in October of
2017.
Initially, it was just him and a couple of
recent college graduates, but despite the
rookie nature of their startup, it didn’t
take long for them to raise a lot of money.
Given Sam’s experience working on Wall Street,
he was able to brand himself as the wall street
professional that was offering crypto trading
services.
Combine this with the fact that the rest of
wall street didn’t want to associate with
crypto at least not publicly, and the extreme
fomo associated with the 2017 bull run, and
Sam was able to raise millions within a few
months.
By January of 2018, Sam was trading $25 million
worth of Bitcoin per day, but this was the
peak of the Bitcoin bull run and things only
went downhill from there.
Sam wasn’t worried about the hype dying
off though as he had sensed a much larger
opportunity.
As he was trading millions of dollars per
day, he noticed that existing crypto brokerages
were trash when it came to trading.
The popular crypto brokerages like Coinbase
had spent all of their effort on making crypto
purchases as seamless as possible for individual
investors.
And while they were phenomenal at this, they
weren’t very good at handling high speed
trade volume from traders.
So, Sam decided to create his own crypto brokerage
that would be tailored towards crypto traders.
Over the next several months, Sam became more
involved with the crypto community by attending
various crypto conferences and meeting with
various crypto investors and traders from
around the world.
After attending a crypto conference in Macau
China, Sam would actually choose to move to
Hong Kong, and this is where he would launch
FTX.
Sam took profits from Alameda and worked with
a couple of venture capital firms to raise
a total of $8 million which he would use to
develop FTX throughout the beginning of 2019.
With $8 million and all of his experience,
Sam was able to develop the perfect platform
for traders, and he eagerly launched FTX in
May of 2019.
But to Sam’s disappointment the launch of
FTX was nothing like the launch of Alameda.
Alameda was launched during the peak of the
bull run when many investors were desperate
to get into crypto.
But by may of 2019, Bitcoin had crashed 80%,
Ethereum had crashed 94% and there was little
to no hype left.
It was basically just the hodlers and bag
holders left and these guys had no interest
in trading.
Sam even hired a dozen salesmen to stand around
at WeWork locations to try to convince traders
to give FTX a shot, but still no one was interested.
So, Sam started to think outside of the box.
Bitcoin no longer had hype, so he couldn’t
rely on momentum traders who rode the wave
up and down.
But, something that Bitcoin still very much
had was volatility.
So, Sam decided to lean in on the volatility
by introducing crypto derivatives.
If you’re not familiar with derivatives,
it’s basically just leveraged trading through
the use of options, futures, and margin.
Now, I cannot understate how dangerous these
are.
Trading derivatives on stocks itself is super
dangerous.
And you could argue that crypto itself is
more dangerous than stock derivatives.
So, when you're trading derivatives on crypto,
you’re basically trading derivatives of
derivatives.
To make things even worse, there’s very
little regulation in crypto trading, so the
leverage you can take is sky high.
On stocks, you’d be hard pressed to find
1x leverage without using options.
Meanwhile, FTX offers up to 20x leverage.
This means that with $10,000 in cash, you
can control $200,000 worth of Bitcoin.
If Bitcoin rises just 5% you double your money,
but the thing that people forget is that if
bitcoin just drops 5%, you lose everything.
I don’t think I need to explain why this
is extremely dangerous.
Ideally, Sam was looking to attract professional
traders who knew the risk and had experience
with leverage.
But naturally, he ended up attracting a large
number of retail gamblers looking for a moonshot
opportunity.
Nonetheless, this was extremely lucrative.
By May of 2020, FTX had grown to 200,000 users
with daily trading volume of $1 billion.
And since then, things have just gone to the
moon.
As of October, FTX boasted a total of 2 million
users with daily trading volume of $11.5 billion.
Now, to put that in perspective, Coinbase
has 68 million users or 34 times FTX.
Yet, they only average about $5 billion per
day in volume which works out to about $74
per person per day.
Meanwhile, FTX averages $5,750 per day per
person.
Now, FTX only charges a fee of 0.005% to 0.07%
per transaction, but with $11.5 billion per
day, we’re talking about somewhere between
half a million per day to 8 million per day.
If we estimate in the middle and call it $4
million, we’re looking at about $1.5 billion
in revenue per year.
And given that the business has very little
overhead, Forbes estimates that their profit
margin is about 50%.
Aside from crypto derivatives, FTX has also
introduced tokens of popular stocks like Apple.
This allows investors from underprivileged
areas to safely participate in the American
stock market.
FTX also introduced their own token which
now accounts for a large part of Sam’s wealth.
Given all of this exposure to crypto, you
would think that Sam is a massive believer
in crypto, but this is actually not the case.
Now, it’s not like Sam is calling for Bitcoin
to go to 0, but he’s also not calling for
it to go to the moon.
He didn’t enter the crypto markets based
on conviction, he entered based on opportunity
and that’s the only reason he’s still
there.
At this point, he’s just hoping that crypto
survives long enough for him to give away
his wealth as the only thing Sam has conviction
in is giving away all his money.
If that’s through crypto and FTX, great,
but if crypto goes down and something else
emerges, he’s just as fine with switching
to that instead.
Right now, he’s reinvesting all of his profits
back into the business given that the company
is only 2.5 years old.
But even through that, he’s managed to donate
$25 million.
Sam hopes that by riding out the crypto wave
and holding off to sell, he can donate over
900 times that or about $22.5 billion.
Now, I don’t want to take away from his
generosity, but I do think it should be noted
that Sam’s donations so far haven’t necessarily
been as altruistic as he originally proposed.
Last year, Sam donated $5.2 million to Joe
Biden’s campaign which made him the second
largest individual donor only beaten out by
Michael Bloomberg.
And I think we can all agree that political
donations are some of the least effective
donations when it comes to altruistic motives.
So, hopefully, Sam does eventually focus on
the altruistic avenues that he originally
described, but only time will tell.
In the meantime, that’s how Sam Bankman
went from 0 to $26.5 billion in just four
years.
Do you guys believe that Sam will actually
follow through and donate all his money.
And if so, do you think his donations will
actually be as altruistic as he describes?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you wish you could make
$26.5 billion in 4 years.
And of course, consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.